[Music]
there are so many games on game pass and
the waves just seem to keep coming and
coming but instead of drowning in all of
it allow me to throw you a lifesaver and
help you give a quick glimpse into some
games that might be worth your time
if you're interested in videos like this
check out the card in the corner we've
done a few so be on the lookout for more
lists like this one and to kicking off
i'm gonna start with one that a lot of
folk have been leaving in the comments
and that is scarlet nexus
set in a near alternate reality future
the world as we know it has been
completely transformed and influenced
after the discovery of a hormone in the
human brain that grants people powers
like psychokinesis
and of course when a new wacky power is
discovered that also means there's loads
of wacky bad stuff to come along with it
like these monsters or as they're known
in the game
as others which is uh kind of well
that's a
very polite way to name a menacing scary
thing anyways they come and start a
bunch of ruckus and that's of course
where you come in because you're the
good person you take the role of one of
two members from the other suppression
force to suppress
the others
here's a new one or well new to game
pass at least aliens fire team elite it
did come out earlier this year but if
you chose to sleep on the team-based
xenomorph shooter then well now is your
time to get a taste of that sweet old
alien battery acid blood squad up with
two friends or ai against hordes of over
20 enemy types there's also five classes
to choose from like a gunner demolisher
technician dock or recon so suit up and
get ready to hear the sounds of that
sweet sweet pulse rifle
with the announcement of alan wake 2
i am now given liberty to just kind of
use anything as an excuse to talk about
alan wake so i'm putting alan wake
american nightmare on this list
it's an action spin-off of the first
game so unfortunately if you haven't
played the first this one
may not make a whole lot of sense to you
just as a heads-up and sadly the first
also isn't on game pass but i highly
recommend it if it floats your way the
remaster just came out so
you know if you get it just let them
know that kurt sent you
anyway in comparison to the first game
american nightmare is more like a pulp
comic book equivalent it's like a
popcorn follow-up trading in most of the
horror psychological thriller vibes for
something more tongue-in-cheek and corky
sprinkled with loads of dark humor and
in the case you have recently finished
the remaster of alan wake well this
continues to scratch that itch this is
also the perfect segway into
control
while i'm on this allen wake too high
i'm just gonna continue to urge you to
play remedy entertainment game so you
should play control 2 after all it has
dlc tying alan wake into the remedy
connected universe and possibly hinting
towards what's to come in its sequel
control is a surrealistic action
metroidvania and it is remedy
entertainment completely unhinged with
stylized brutalist architecture
incredible powers exploration world
building and spine tingling storytelling
that constantly subverted my
expectations along the way and i was
basically obligated to mention this
alongside alan wake so yeah can't say
the same for quantum break however which
is also in game pass and uh well i don't
have the same enthusiasm to share as
remedy's other games but hey for what
it's worth i actually had a lot of fun
with quantum break i just don't remember
anything that happened in it
deep rock galactic i'm shouting this out
thanks to a comment from buckling
swashes as the comment mentions yeah
this one's kind of a game pass classic
at this point but like a lot of games
that are ever growing like sea of
thieves or no man's sky it deserves to
get a new and improved shout out every
time it gets uh well new and improved
just in october deep rock galactic the
four player co-op sci-fi shooter got the
rival incursion update that's among the
first major updates for the game to
develop more of a narrative into the
game it's got new mission types enemies
weapons cosmetics and all that stuff
in the ever-growing genre of simulation
where it takes menial tasks that people
seem to not enjoy doing in real life and
then somehow gamifying them in a way
that we all want to play them we now
have lawn mowing simulator for what it's
worth i don't actually have a lawn which
means i don't have a lawnmower to mow it
nor do i live in the british countryside
and this game features all of that which
is actually a really compelling case to
make something i normally would dread
doing kind of enjoyable considering i
don't have any of it really my only
cultural connection to the british
countryside is midsummer murders and
according to that show neighbors just
practically murder each other over who
has a nicer lawn so in a way i can play
this game and imagine like i'm the dude
who mows the nice lawn of the
prospective victim in the next episode
and that's cool right anyways it's a
game where you mow lawns as implied by
its title lawn mowing simulator
have you ever just laid a wick deep into
the night thinking what it would be like
if david cronenberg made oregon trail
yeah well me neither but we now know
what that's like because space warlord
oregon trading simulator is basically
that it's a tycoon style game but for
body horror it's a fast-paced trading
sim because organs are a hot commodity
in this universe and they're going quick
you gotta compete with other traders
deal with the natural happenstance of
organs leaking in cargo or even
exploding because that's a thing all you
gotta know is that this game is from the
lead writer hypnose space outlaw which
is also on game pass and is also quite a
unconventional and riveting experience
to say the least and here's something
weird if you're gaming on an xbox one
and just so happen to have your connects
still well uh this game has connect
functionality so yeah
connect getting support in 2021 because
why the [ __ ] not
if you have game pass ultimate then you
need to give it takes two a try but as
its name implies it's a multiplayer game
only thankfully you only need one copy
of the game in order to play with
someone else additionally if you're not
playing couch co-op with someone and
you're playing online it still shares
the player's view regardless which is a
really nice touch as the game requires
constant communication so seeing what
your player is doing is pretty much
vital to most of the game it takes two
is a master class and changing its
mechanics up constantly making sure the
player never gets too comfortable but
equally shifts gears just as something
starts to get a little boring
it also has some of the most creative
level design i've played in all of 2021
probably right next to psychonauts 2.
it's a rom-com romp that'll test your
skills as a player and possibly the
relationship of whoever you're playing
with if you end up digging it takes two
make sure to give a way out a shot it's
the same developer but it's more of a
campy buddy prison breakout game
[Music]
code vane it's another game a few of you
have mentioned in the comments so here
you go it's a co-op action game that'll
find you journeying to the depths of
hell to understand who you are and
escape a dire and crumbling world
through this destroyed landscape there's
dudes with big collars and cool hair
using big swords and wearing sweet masks
along the way you'll fight big menacing
monster things and drink blood in the
process because in this world you're a
remnant and remnants have to drink blood
or else they turn into big horrifying
creatures known as the loss which are
the exact things you're murdering so
that's it either you drink blood and you
slay giant ass monsters or you don't
drink blood or you become the giant ass
monsters you have to slay not that
that's a thing in the game but that's
what a remnant is or else you become a
big monster it's just a plot device okay
now along with all those games that just
listed off as of today mortal kombat 11
the gunk and broken age among many many
others were just added to game pass
now of those three the gunk is actually
an entirely new title so i have no idea
what's going on there but i'm excited to
at least check it out because why not
okay we're done hopefully that's enough
to keep you afloat through this holiday
season or you can just ignore this list
entirely and go back to playing halo
infinite or if you're me
skyrim and yes just so no one calls me
on the comments hades is on game pass
too so
there'll be a lot of people there saying
you should go play it so why not just go
and give it a shot
alright there i did my due diligence
okay till next time see you later